We can do this, the same sort of invention of new events were
appropriate to make sure that all of the news cases that we started out with
actually cause the machine or make the radio behave in a way we like or
behave. Well, we're going to stop the exercise here, but
there's some things which we would still have to do to get a complete model.
Although this model process, we have undertaken seems quite long there's still
some things we'd have to do. We'd have to indicate what the default states for
each of the concurrent machines is. Recall that for
a state machine we can indicate what the state is when we turn things on, and
we would need to do that for these concurrent machines.
We would have to place the guards on the transitions where required, and
we'd have to invent these in, internal events.
The results of this process can be seen in, in the diagram shown here.
[BLANK_AUDIO]